okay hello everyone welcome to today's
webinar the top three ways order flow
will improve your trading my name is
Michael valos I'm the founder of order
flows.com my promise to you today is
I'll show you exactly how to use
orderflow to find and take better trades
and give you the confidence to trade
successfully by reducing your losing
trades taking more winning trades and
understanding why a trade is not working
out I mean nobody wants to to trade if
you're not making money I mean there's
no point right so if you stay until the
end I'm going to give you a bonus I'm
going to give you my ebook entitled
hidden trade opportunities which will
show you the power in using orderflow
analysis in your trading now before we
get started a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results now I need your attention please
turn off your cell phones turn off
Facebook if you're a Trader who wants to
add what is for many the final piece of
information to their trading and you're
serious about getting better results by
adding order flow to your trading the
next 60 to 90 minutes will change your
life
okay so again you know for those that
don't know me my name is Michael Volos
and you know a little bit of a
background on me I was an Institutional
Trader for 20 years at tier one
investment Banks JP Morgan Commerce Bank
and the big commodity trading firms
Cargill and EDF man I've traded Futures
markets all over the world alongside
many of the best Traders you've heard of
and many you have not heard of trust me
you know the the ones that write books
and you know run hedge funds
that make the news yeah you hear about
them but trust me there's there's many
many more behind them that are just as
brilliant and you never hear about them
you know they just they have a
workmanlike procedure I also wrote a
book on orderflow trading it's 150 Pages
the guide to orderflow trading orderflow
and you
know it's really like I want say the
culmination of all my experience but you
know I wrote it a few years ago and you
know at that time I I just really wanted
to put my my knowledge down on paper and
I started writing I didn't think it' get
to be 150 Pages you know everyone says
oh I could write a book but when you sit
down and you start writing you it keeps
getting longer and longer and longer um
you know and then I I wrote it then I
realized there's still a lot more
information that that's not in that book
you know I've gone on I've created
trading courses and so on I put out
videos orderflow is not like you know
everything is out there that you know
you know there's still things being
discovered with orderflow and you know
one of the reasons why I do you know
these presentations and speak to other
Traders is to learn how other people are
using it and get it out there for
everybody you know I spent part of my
time at JP Morgan mentoring new Traders
on how to read what's happening in the
Futures market after I left JP Morgan I
realized much of the information out
there on order flow is just pure garbage
you know it's often spoused by people
who never traded professionally and what
I mean is you know when I say trade
professionally I don't necessarily mean
they have to trade at a bank or you know
a big commodity trading firm or a prop
shop I'm talking about people that trade
you know to pay their bills you know to
pay their mortgage pay their rent pay
their car payment put their kids in
school put food on the table and you
know it it really kind of upsets me when
I see um people writing stuff on forums
you know that you know maybe have just
started trading orderflow for two months
and all of a sudden they think they're
an expert um you know take it from me
you know I've I've been around the
markets long enough I know I can tell
when someone is is bullshitting their
way and you know when someone actually
has a lot of knowledge you know the ones
that have the knowledge they they don't
the ones that you know raise their hand
and say yeah I know everything you know
they're very humble and you know they're
willing to share with you you know but
but the ones that you know try to beat
you down because you you speak up you
know those are the people you want to
stay away from and you know as a
successful Trader I was able to retire
from JP Morgan which is the last company
that I worked
for and the whole investment banking
industry you know at the age of 43 um
you know that's you know I I always
wanted to retire before I was 50 I had
the opportunity to do it you know much
younger and now I get it's great you
know I get to spend time with my family
I get to see my kids growing up you know
I get to go with my daughter to to her
school whenever I want and you know it's
just fantastic you know this is the life
that trading has afforded me you know
that freedom that's that's what you want
in life you want freedom when I
started in this business I knew nobody
in the industry I had no connections I
literally started at the bottom of the
food chain as a runner on the SE floor I
made 25 cents higher than minimum wage
at the time and I even slept on my
brother's sofa for three months okay
granted it was a nice sofa but you know
that's how I got started um you know I
didn't I wasn't born you know my daddy
didn't have a a membership I know guys
that you know that parents had
memberships or their uncle and
grandfather had memberships on the
exchange you know that's how they got in
I I literally just you know got my foot
in the door and went from
there okay so you know just you know
make it a little bit more personal you
know this is me um you know this is me
now here in the bottom corner with my
family you know I got three kids um you
know this is up on the top left is is a
picture of me at at Commerce Bank um you
know I was I was always the I want say
the Casual one but you know everyone
else would have wear the you didn't have
to wear a tie in the office but I would
just wear a t-shirt um you know JP
Morgan is very instrumental in getting
JP Morgan into other as Asian countries
you know this is from our our our joint
venture in China um actually one of
these guys here in the middle here this
is me in the back the guy in front of me
now runs City Banks uh Futures Trading
division the guy next to him is is the
one that runs the Asian Pacific for uh
JP Morgan and you know this is my
picture here you know after after I left
about a year after I left this is just
last last Halloween and you know I could
act silly now you know I mean I don't
have to you know dress up in a tie or
you know or anything like that I could
just you know live and enjoy life with
my kids you know when your kids are
young then you know that's the time you
want to spend with them not you know not
when they're teenagers and they all want
to get out of the house you want them
spend that time when they're growing up
so imagine what your life would be like
when you understand what is happening in
the market and the confidence to trade
successfully you don't have to worry
about too many losing trades or because
you don't understand why your trades
constantly lose ever again I mean you'll
with order flow yes you will have losing
trades I'll say that you know don't
expect that you're not going to have
losing trades but at least you know
you'll I'll say you'll feel better
knowing why you lost
but at least you know you'll feel better
in the sense that
you can accept your losses you know
sometimes people get so you know they
have a loss and they beat themselves up
over it and you know that that's that's
not going to help your trading you know
you I'm not saying you're going to be
totally objective but at least you'll
understand what's happening in the
market and you could accept your losses
and move on move on to the next trade
because you know what the next trade
could be the one that you know makes up
for the last two or three bad
trades so what will your life like when
you know how simple orderflow trade
setups that you can look for each day in
the markets you know offer you lowrisk
entries with high potential returns you
know what if you could come into each
day you know with a with a group of
trading um setups you know in your mind
that you're going to look for that you
know when you see them you take them
right you don't have to sit there and
scratch your head and say oh you know
what we're coming up to this uh
hopefully we'll hit this 200 day moving
average no I mean you'll be watching the
market you know it'll be speaking to you
literally you'll be anticipating when
you should be taking
trades and you know imagine what it'll
be like when you really know how
orderflow will help you limit your risk
in a trade you know what difference will
that make for your trading you know for
you for your family you know
if you if you can know that you know
your risk is fairly even more limited
than you previously imagined you know
I'm going to get into this later when
I'm talking about stops you know people
that I meet you know new Traders they
just arbitrarily Place their stops and
sometimes it's quite far away and the
risk is is too big and you know when
you're using order flow you the Market's
going to tell you put your stop here
because based on the order flow you know
if we get you know if we retrace back to
this level the whole reason for the
trade just sort of falls apart and
there's really no reason to be in that
trade anymore you don't have to wait
till it goes literally to all the way to
your stop price and and stop you out at
the at the the full risk you know if you
once you're able to read the order flow
and what's unfolding in the market then
you know you you'll be a step ahead of
everybody else you know you're not going
to be risking I mean you'll still be
risking the full amount but you know if
you could reduce your loss from say $500
to
$100 you know you'll be in the long run
you'll be ahead so again you know these
are just some of you know the proof that
you know what I do is I I think is
legitimate for Traders you know honestly
orderflows is not for everybody you know
I wish it was but honestly you know it's
just not for for everybody and you know
some of my customers you know this zad
thanks for this um this is on on the
YouTube page you know I put a lot of
videos up on YouTube and you know he
says hey Mike this is simply great you
know folks who don't see the value in
what you're sharing are simply missing
the point positives that put on the
table are massively valuable for any
Trader who's willing to learn trading as
a career and not as a casino hit you
know thanks again for all the great work
it's very
valuable and massively
appreciated okay you know another one
you know it's bad thing for us you close
your trading room it's reopened but you
know it was just closed cuz I has taken
a break not everyone is able to
understand the value of your experience
and high quality of your tools you can
be selective you know by a mean or
another and let the door open for one
that listen and there's the judge the
work of others without any success in
the field okay so I mean that's out
there you know on on my
on my YouTube page you know again I try
to put a lot of information out there
for free um you know I mean because you
know this information you know it's
information that I've learned over these
years and you know I try to share it
whenever possible now results are not
typical but you know I'll walk you
through the methods Traders are using to
get great results please understand that
my results are not typical because the
average person who attends any training
gets zero results it's one thing to
attend a trading but you got to put what
I'm talking about to action okay you
mean you could watch all the videos read
all the books but you know what if
you're not going to put it
in you know in action if you're not
going to form a plan of action and
follow it up you're not going to get
anywhere okay um I mean you know I've
got a library of trading books literally
constantly buying books on markets I
whenever I go to use bookstore I'm
always looking for books you know it's I
don't use everything that I read in in
these books you know I'm I'm more of a
collector but still you know the point
is
you know if you're going to be trying to
learn something and not apply it there's
probably not much of a reason to to
learn it you know I mean funny thing is
you know when you're in school right and
you're sitting there in algebra class
and you're going to say oh I'm never
going to use math again in my life you
know what do I need to take algebra or
trigonometry and then when you get out
of school you realize hey you know what
actually I I do use that I just didn't
realize it at the
time now I'm happy to share with you for
free exactly what's working for me right
I I got no qualms sharing it um cuz I
know that not everybody's going to use
it you know I mean it'd be great if
everybody did the same thing as me
because you know that then everything
would become a self-fulfilling prophecy
and I would be even making more money
but still you know I I do realize that
you know sometimes people are skeptical
sometimes people are set in their ways
and you know sometimes people are just
lazy and don't want to do the work I
mean that's fine whatever you fall into
is is great more power to you but for
the ones that really want to learn and
you know really make a living
trading you know pay their bills with
trading
profits they want to sit down and they
want to learn right and they want to
learn from somebody that's done it you
know that's been in their shoes you know
that's traded professionally someone
that's earned their living their
livelihood
trading the markets you know I mean you
know anybody could go open a a Forex
account for a couple hundred bucks trade
micro accounts and you know for like 10
cents a a pip and say oh I'm a Trader
you know but there's a big difference
between you know trading a a simple you
know a $2,000 Forex account and trying
to live on that as opposed to you know
trading your own personal account with
literally you know every expense that
you know a person has to pay you know
whether it's you know Medical whether
it's you know your house whether it's
your car school fees everything right um
there there's you got to be successful
at it and the best way to learn is from
people that have been doing it for a
living you know paying their bills by by
trading so anyway what we'll cover today
is I said the you know the topways
orderflow
will make you a better Trader is you you
know I I say secet SEC but not really
Secrets right this is just pure
information that you know people don't
realize so number one orderflow allows
you to see into the price bar and see
the volume traded to know what's really
occurring in the markets okay you know
if you're just looking at a normal bar
chart you're not going to see any
information you're not going to you're
going to treat every price the same when
not every price actually is the
same number two using arbitrary levels
for stops based on dollar mons is not
very specific uh scientific or prudent
okay and I'll show you how to play stops
at levels where the reason for being in
a trade is no longer there so you know
instead of risking say $500 on a trade
you could risk you know $200 so your
risk is actually going to be lesser you
know it it kills me when I when I see
people drawing lines on chart and say oh
you know you have a support here or
resistance here then you place should
stop way up here and it's so far away so
it's like my goodness um what's the
logic behind it and you know number
three know the more lines you have drawn
on your chart the more confusing it
becomes it's information
overload and you know using an orderflow
chart you know while at first it looks
intimidating it's it's actually not it's
very elegant and you know easy to read
once you know what to look at so what is
orderflow analysis well it's the natural
expression of the market you know the
volume traded organized in a format
that's easy to read that a Trader can
make objective trading decisions so
really quick this is an orderflow chart
this is just from the other day and it's
a NASDAQ chart and you can see you
honestly at first when you first look at
it you're like huh what the hell is this
but actually you know I'm going to
explain in this webinar what most of
this means okay I can't explain
everything in in this short in a short
period of time but number one orderflow
allows you to see into the price bar and
see the volume that's traded to know
what's really occurring in the market
so why is that important well again you
know going back to if you're just
looking at a normal bar chart you're
treating every price the same you know
whether it traded two lots or whether it
traded 2,000 lots and there's a big
difference whether you trade two lots or
2,000 Lots often times you know
if you know a price level is is going to
be a support level but it only traded
you know a very small amount you know is
it really going to be a support level or
you know if if you saw in a traded 2,000
then yeah you that would be a support
level but you know if you don't use that
information in your analysis you're
really leaving um you know a lot of I
don't want to say money on the table but
information you know on the table you
mean it's information that you can use
you know it's it's it's like you know I
don't want to say playing a you know
playing a sports game you know football
or something but you know you have a
Playbook right and you know you know how
when defenses line up a certain way you
know you know generally what's going to
happen on that play and it's the same
thing
with orderflow right when you see
orderflow sort of coming in in a certain
way you can sort of anticipate what's
going to happen next so you when you see
the volume and understand what you're
looking at you'll know who's in control
know traders who want to add the final
piece of information to their trading
you that's what we all want to do you
know lots of Traders are you know I I I
get a lot of people that come up to me
they're actually very good Traders but
they're very close to break even you
know maybe their borderline you know one
month they make money next month they
lose a little bit next month they Mak
money it just goes back and forth and
it's like they feel so so close know so
close that they can just taste it and
they just feel like they're just missing
something and that's oftentimes that is
order flow right I mean I know guys that
are great at finding levels in the
market and there's times that the levels
are really solid and and work
tremendously and there's times where
they don't work out you know then like
oh what's the can you help me let's take
a look at this with orderflow and you
know we found often times you with order
flow they can refine their entries you
know they don't take you know levels
that you know aren't backed up confirmed
with the order
flow and you know if if you treat all
prices the same again you're assuming
that you know a trade where it traded
two contracts is going to be as
the same as you know a price level where
it traded 2,000 contracts well there's
going to be a big difference right
there's either very little activity or
there could be average or there could be
a lot of activity and you know each sort
of level of activity you know has
different meanings right I mean you
can't treat them all the same and you
know orderflows the orderflow trader
software which is the software that's
used to generate the charts that you see
here you know neatly summarizes all the
data into an easyto read chart
so what do I mean with all this
information seeing inside the price bar
oh that's great but you know what am I
looking at so there's several things
okay there's PLC I'm going to get into
these PLC which stands for point of
control um imbalances and the Delta so
point of control you know the P referred
to you know a lot of people see you
you'll see the term PC or just say PC
it's a lot easier to say than point of
control all the time it's the level
where the most volume trades in a bar
and it's going to be marked with a box
okay and often times in a market that's
moving it's going to be support or
resistance so on a market that's moving
up it'll often be support and you can
see here you have a swing low come down
within a couple of ticks of that then
you got a new point of control right
here what do you do you come down right
to that level got a new point of control
come down within a couple ticks next bar
come down you get through it by a tick
here the next bar get down right to a
tick this next bar you get down one tick
Above This Bar here um you know you come
right down to that tick
and you know that that's like you I
always use the the old
um fairy tale I say fairy tale but you
know the old story you know when your a
kid growing up Jack in the bean stock
you know where guy's like hey I got
these magic beans You Know Jack do you
want to buy them and it's
like you know when when I first learned
about
overflow you know it's you know it was
almost like somebody pulled me aside and
said hey how how would you like to know
where support or resistance can be in
the next bar based on the current bar
that you're in you know and that's what
point of control often is you know on a
market that's
moving okay so imbalances now the next
thing I want to talk about you know so
you have a bar right and you have
numbers inside okay and and honestly you
know it it it's it can be intimidating
you know people just don't like numbers
and you see black numbers you see red
numbers num you see blue numbers and
black numbers are just your normal
volume blue numbers inside the bar is a
buying imbalance the red numbers are
selling imbalances now remember markets
you know how Futures markets trade right
it's bid and offered okay so when you're
going to compare a price you're going to
compare not horizontally but diagonally
so 585 against 69 you know 79 3 against
390 515 against 1286 you're not going to
compare it zero against 69 585 against
390 793 against 1286 or 515 against 212
no that's that's
incorrect how you compare it is from the
bid against the offer so when it's you
know say 10 bid at 11 you see what's
trading on the bid you see what's
trading on the offer right because you
know the market can stay bid and offer
you know for really quick or it could
stay there bid for several minutes or
you know however long
and when you trade right you either work
a bid you work an offer or you sell into
the bid or you buy the
offer
and what orderflow volume footprint
charts do is they record how it's being
traded so when you look at this 585
against 69 okay so say this Market is 10
bid at 11 okay so when it was 10 bid at
11 there were
585 people that sold into this bid here
okay and 69 people bought the offer and
when there's an imbalance is when the
ratio 585 against 689 is more than 400%
you can actually adjust it it seems the
industry standard is 400 okay just like
11 against 293 you know when the
Market's 8 bid at 9 you know it traded
11 on the bid and 293 on the offer
that's a buying imbalance so the red is
a selling imbalance so when the Market's
10 11 you had you know more than 400%
people selling into the bid then bought
the offer and why is that important well
it tells
you often times you know who's in
control of the market who's being
aggressive in the
market you would call people selling at
the market you know selling into the bid
or buying the offer the aggressive party
the people that are working working a
bid or working an offer are passive and
the best way to describe it I think is
when you go to buy a car okay say you're
going to buy the new um BMW 5 series
okay you go into the dealership and the
price of the car is
$60,000 okay the dealer is saying I'll
sell you the car at
$60,000 okay so he's being he's putting
an offer out there for the car at
$60,000 you say well I like the car but
I'm going to bid $50,000 for it so
you're bidding $50,000 for the car the
car dealer's offering it at 60,000 so
you're a passive buyer he's a passive
seller no trade is going to happen until
either you go up to his offer or he goes
down to your bid you know so if the
dealer says oh you know what I got a big
shipment of cars coming in next week and
I'm going to be you I'm have an extra 30
cars I need to sell these cars okay I'll
tell you what 50,000 done he goes down
hits your bid and you just bought a car
for
$50,000 so the dealer he was aggressive
right because he wants to sell the car
so he went basically went to the market
and sold it at the bid price your bid of
50,000
now if you the buyer right if you're
like thinking I really need this car
because you know what I got uh you know
my I got a date next week with this girl
really want to impress her and I need it
okay I'm fine 60,000 done you know you
paid the market price you paid the offer
the dealer was offering at 60,000 you
were the aggressive buyer because you
want to get this done you want this car
so you're willing to pay what the offer
price is you are the aggressive buyer
the dealer he's happy to sell it to you
you know whether you come in and buy it
at 60,000 he doesn't really care because
he knows you know this car is in demand
and if he doesn't sell it to you he can
sell it to somebody else probably
tomorrow for the same $60,000 so he's
passively selling it and you are
aggressively buying it so and when the
ratio between what's the bid volume and
the offer volume is more than 400% like
I said you could adjust it I know people
that use a setting of
800% okay which is basically 8 to1 and
they have a whole trading strategy built
around that okay but the industry
standard is about 400%
and you know even with imbalances okay
now why I say why is important you know
you know who's in control of the market
is you know sort of leading to the next
thing you know really quick I'm not
going to talk much about it today I mean
this probably the only time we talking
about is what they call Stacked
imbalances buying like if you have three
or more imbalances stacked on top of
each other one two three you know in a
row and often what that means I mean
obviously it means people are being
aggressive but it's also a support level
if it's a buy bu imbalance or resistance
level if it was three selling imbalances
stacked on each other there's no selling
IM balance in here but you can see how
this Market how it holds as a level
because you know if the market comes
back down ideally what you want to see
is the aggressive buyers coming back in
and buying it because they like this
this price level for whatever reason and
you often see how the market reacts to
it the market will often shoot up or
shoot you know if it's a selling
imbalance continue down in the near
term and you know the Third I want to
talk about is Delta Delta is the
difference between the volume traded on
the bid less the volume traded on the
offer and it will show up on the bottom
of a chart and generally on a market
moving down you'll have negative Deltas
on a market moving up you'll have
positive Deltas okay there's going to be
times sometimes where they they don't
match up sometimes you have a negative
Delta on a on an up bar or a positive
Delta on a down bar but in
general it shows you one who's in
control if you're going to be moving
away from a a high high or a low you
know if you're going to be moving away
from a low look for positive Deltas
right because you can't move away from a
low unless you're starting to string
together positive Deltas over over
several bars you know if you get in a
bar with positive Delta the negative
Delta positive Delta negative Delta
small Delta it's not very you know it's
not very strong right you're not really
going to be moving away any time
soon but you know so it's a it's a tool
that you know can help you refine your
trades and keep you out of bad trades
you know it's not necessarily about
finding all the winning trades it's also
about keeping you away from trades that
are borderline you know the borderline
trades are the ones that you know have
about as much chance of working as as
they do failing so if you can eliminate
some of those then you know you'll be a
little bit ahead of of everybody else
that's that's taking this these trades
that don't use orderflow and they're
taking the trades and suffering losses
and when you put these three basic tools
of order flow together the market really
starts to make sense okay so you like I
said Delta you know if you're moving up
look for you know positive Deltas right
you're going up here positive Delta
positive Delta now you're starting down
you got negative Delta negative Delta
negative
Delta P acting as support on the way up
right you can see here you got you know
again you're it's holding you know the
Market's not retracing down through it
now on the way down it's acting as
resistance right your point of control
is here you come up with an tick here it
comes right up to that tick here this
bar goes lower you know it's green bar
pops back up where does it where do we
trade back you know over the next two
bars it comes right up to that previous
point of
control you know you have buying
imbalances on the way up you know you're
having you can see the aggressive buyers
coming in you buying imbalance here
buying imbalance there selling
imbalances on the way down you got a
selling imbalance here s and balance
here here as the Market's going lower so
you know
this is just basic orderflow stuff you
know if you're not using this
information you know and you're just
looking at normal candlesticks or even
bars I don't know who you still people
still use bars boggles my mind but you
know this is information that
really you know is once you once you use
orderflow for a week you know you watch
the charts it really starts clearing
everything up and honestly I don't think
you'd ever go back to another type of
bar chart without orderflow now you know
secret number two with orderflow is you
know your stop levels people use
arbitrary levels for stops based on
dollar amounts and again that's not very
scientific and it's not very prudent
actually um you know I you do need to
use stops okay and you know if you don't
have a way of using stops to you know
tighten your risk lower your risk then
you know I'd rather you use them than
not use them so but I'm going to show
you how to play stops at levels where
you know the reason for being in a trade
is you know it's no longer there I mean
you know if if you're in a trade and
it's not working out and you can see in
the orderflow why it's not working out
then get out I mean there's no shame in
getting out of a trade early you know
it's not ride or die right I mean if if
the Market's turning on you and you
could recognize it then then you get
out so you know
don't use arbitrary stop levels right
now you know most Traders think stops
will limit their risk and yeah and and
they will okay to a certain extent you
know it's we've all suffered slippage on
stops you know what slippage is you know
is is where your stop level is to where
you actually get filled and sometimes
you know you could lose a tick or two I
mean sometimes in volatile markets you
could lose a lot more than a thick or
two and actually you know using
arbitrary levels
for stops is is just kind
of I don't say not useful but you know
sometimes is actually counterproductive
you know it's much better to use
stops based on what the market is
telling you right what saying the market
is saying hey you know what the reason
for being in this trade is no longer
there so again you know if you know a
big fallacy Traders have is they think
stops will limit their risk there's no
guarant
you know the stops are not guaranteed um
you know you could blow through a stop
in a IL liquid Market if youve ever had
a stop go off during a Fed announcement
during the non-farm payrolls um you
you'll know exactly what I mean you know
I mean I've seen stops literally I'm not
even talking about on the floor I mean
I'm talking electronically you know
stocks you know in snps which is a very
liquid Market I've seen stops you know
suffer you know six ticks of slippage
right and and that's a market right the
snps is a market where you know there's
thousands aside generally cuz you know
on the screen there'll be 100 but
there's usually you know another 5 600
hidden behind that so you know there's
going to be times where you do suffer
worse losses and if you could place a
stop at a level where the market simply
telling you hey the reason for being in
the trade is no longer there get then
you know to get out right these are stop
levels that make sense and what do I
mean you know for perfect example okay
so remember before I was talking about
imbalances stacked imbalances right so
here's a stacked buying
imbalance and you know if you're getting
long in here thinking hey you know what
I'm going to get long you know we're
starting to you can see we're sort of
inching our way up you got to stack buy
and balance here again you'd be thinking
okay this is going to be a support level
right and you know if you're trading a
breakout okay cuz you had this double
top here and you're finally breaking out
through
it you know people where are they going
to put their stop well they'll put their
stop way down here you know why well
that's because you know that's the low
down here but if you're trading you know
the breakout and you see hey I got a
buying imbalance here some aggressive
buying and then it starts going up
you're thinking great because you got in
here somewhere then you see it start
coming back down back into this area
where you had the stack buying imbalance
all of a sudden you got a A selling
imbalance there that that's not a good
sign you know the Market's telling you
hey you know you might want to think
about getting out of this position
because you know we got a little pop up
maybe it's a false breakout but you know
aggressive sellers are coming back in
and you can see we trade all the way
back down so would you rather get
stopped out up here you know at 57 or
down here at 55 you know you could take
you know maybe a small loss maybe break
even even on the trade you know again
there's nothing wrong with um getting
out of a trade early if you can see you
know if the market is telling you to get
out of the trade
and you know again you know take a small
loss instead of uh instead of a big one
now this one is this is a little bit
more
um what's the term you know complex um
there's a few things but you know one of
the things I talk about is you know so
this Red Line This is the low you know
you can it's always good to print have
your chart print the daily low the daily
high so at least you know like when
you're coming into a low or coming into
a high for the day because you know
whenever you test these
levels it could be significant and so
we're we you know we hit the low here
you know this a f minute chart so you
you hit the little twice start rallying
up and you can see how the point of
controls you know so you thinking hey I
I get long you know I can get long in
here okay cuz you know hey we got this
double bottom we're starting to move
away I'm going to get long then you just
go sideways okay then you come down and
and make new lows right you're you're
trying to buy here thinking hey we're
we're going to start moving away from
the low you know we got a at the low we
got a negative Delta but next bar you
positive Delta higher point of control
higher point of
control and you again another strong
positive Delta but then you just go
sideways here and you know if you're not
using order flow say you're just looking
at these candles you're thinking hey I
got a double bottom you know two bars at
the bottom and you're starting to move
up okay you got you know if you're using
swings you know you got hey I got a I
got a higher low you know on a higher
high and you just go sideways and this
is you know this is the beauty of order
flows you can see here hey you know you
got point of controls all lined up here
1 2 three then four even um one tick
below and you know in some of the
Advanced Training I get into you know
looking at the point of controls and if
once they're lined up like this 1 two
three that's often a sign of a market
going sideways and the next thing is
right if you're watching the the Delta
negative you'll see negative negative
negative it's even getting stronger so
sellers are coming back in right you're
you're looking for the Delta to be if
you're going to move away from the low
you want to see the Delta get stronger
to the positive you want to see
aggressive buyers coming in and instead
you see the difference you sort of move
away and then you're going sideways but
what's very important is -221 - 446 -300
so what you're seeing you're seeing
sellers starting to take control of the
market okay because
again you know the Delta what's the
definition the Delta is the net
difference between buyers and sellers in
a bar so sellers are over when it's
negative sellers are in control and
they're getting stronger 221 400
1,300 and what happens you fall over so
there's a few things in here with the
order flow you can see the
Delta's kind of you know was was strong
going up but then when you get up here
see the market going sideways the point
of controls lining up and you see the
Delta getting strong negative so it
tells you that sellers are starting to
grab control of this Market by its neck
and chances are we're going to make new
lows and you go lower so you know again
if if you're buying this thinking hey
you know this low this is going to be
the low I want to get long and you get
long in here where you going to place
your stop I mean you know the most
realistic place is below this low okay
um what is this low we'll call it uh
2350 so you're going to place your
stop sorry 2350 and you're going to
place your stop you know maybe 2350 tick
or two below the low but if you're
watching the orderflow you could see
this the Delta you can see these points
of controls you can see the selling
imbalances in here quite big um you know
500 300 you know you do have a a
positive one there but you know what can
you do nevertheless um you know even in
here 200 even here 200 and you know when
it's sitting here at 512 and you're sort
of long at 51 and A2 you you could
scratch the trade you could take a tick
loss two ticks loss would you rather
take um you know get out here at you
know 51 a half as opposed to getting out
at 49 and you know getting stopped out
at you know 49 and 3/4 49 and a half or
even even 50 somewhere down here or
would you rather get out up here you
know that's how order flow can help
you have better stops you know lower
your risk um on a trade you know I I
understand that it does take some
thinking I I know people just want to
buy and boom boom it's that's their
takeprofit and and their stop in there
but again you know if you're trading to
pay your
bills any way you can
reduce a loss right whether you know if
if you're saving one point right one
point in the S&P is is 50 bucks right if
if you can reduce you know 50 bucks out
of every losing trade you know say
you're trading five Lots that's 250
bucks right and you know if you just do
that once a day that's an extra 250
bucks that you're not giving back to the
market and you know at the you just add
it up you know if if that you do that
you're trading five lot you do it once a
day it's 250 bucks a day at the end of
the week it's
1,250 end of a month what is that 5,000
bucks what would you do with an extra
5,000 bucks bucks in your trading
account you know a month I'm not talking
about a year I'm talking about a month
you know that's a lot of money and you
know that stuff adds
up but people don't necessarily think
about it you know it's again it's not
ride or die let it you'll go all the way
to your profit level or to your stop
level again you know if you can get out
of a trade because it's not working out
and you could recognize that it's not
working out it's much better to get out
early I mean you know that that that's a
hard thing for people to grasp actually
it sounds simple but um you know for
some
people it's it's like a foreign concept
I mean you know but hopefully now you
can understand how using orderflow could
help you recognize when a trade is not
working out so again you know don't wait
for a trade to go to your stop if the
market is telling you something
different if it's telling you get out
then then get out you know you don't
have
to be married to the trade that it's you
know it's either got to stop me out or
it's got to go am I takeprofit no get
out of the trade early if it's not
working out I mean again there's there's
no shame in getting out of a trade early
no one's going to say haha you got out
of the trade early you're an idiot you
know there's going to be times yet maybe
it does work out maybe it doesn't work
out but ultimately it does work out much
better than it not working out again you
know it's trading I say one of the
beauties of trading you know the way the
market is it's it's Anonymous you know
you're trading on a computer you don't
see the other side of the trade in the
sense that you know you don't you're not
it's not like playing cards right or
you're sitting across from the the guy
that you're whose money you're trying to
take um you know there's there's many
different reasons people are in the
markets and so there's no shame in
getting out of a trade early if you want
you could always get back
in you know you could do whatever you
want right I mean but again you know
people don't grasp the concept of
getting out of a trade early if it's not
working out and honestly for a lot of
people the way that they trade using
indicators using chart-based
indicators they don't know that a
trade's not working out until it goes to
their stop price it may just go sideways
and you know they don't know you know
cuz they're not analyzing what's
actually being traded in the market so
you know hopefully you know that makes
you know that can resonate with some
people now I realize you know I'm
talking about a lot of different things
some of it will resonate with some
people some won't and you know hopefully
some of the things I talk about will
resonate with you and you know if they
said you know there's many different
aspects of
orderflow not everything is for
everybody you know I people have adopted
one or two things from orderflow and
it's just made all the difference in
their trading you don't have to adopt
everything it' be nice if you did you
know I do think I'll make you a complete
Trader but like I said you know people
that I've worked with that have traded
in the past you know they have ways of
trading already and they're adding order
flow to it right to help refine it and
and make their existing way of trading
better and you know stop placement is a
big thing I mean risk management in a
trade is just as important as finding
good entries and and decent exits um you
know I mean you could have the best
signals that give the best trading
signals but if you can't manage the
trade after you're in it you know over
time you'll crash and burn so you know
order flow will improve your trading by
you know making your stop placement more
intelligence and secret number three is
you know the more indicators and lines
you have drawn on your chart the more
confusing it becomes you know it's
information overload and again you know
I I was never strong in math I mean I'll
be I'll be honest I had to take calculus
twice in in college and it got to the
point where I was my last semester of
senior year I had to get a passing grade
um in calculus to graduate and if I
didn't get it the minimum I wouldn't
graduate and I mean I did but uh you
know
it you know people see numbers and they
think math and they get scared and I
think that's why people like to use
indicators is because indicators does
the math for them that they don't have
to do it now that said um you know
orderflow you're not using math or
you're using some math but not much per
se so don't worry wor about that I mean
like I said people get scared with
numbers when you look at an orderflow
chart you see a lot of numbers uh it
just turns people off but it's actually
you know you're not trading every single
you're not living and dying every single
tick the way you are you know if you're
trading with a dome um you know you
really you're just you're looking for
those points in the market
when the Market's telling you something
lots of times it doesn't tell you
anything because you know the markets
exist to facilitate trade and that's
what the market does most of the time
it's the times when something
of the normal routine of trading occurs
that you want to be alerted to and again
you know order flows it's a very elegant
chart you know I call it the lightsaber
of trading and just because it's it's
very elegant and it's tells you much
much more information than any other
type of chart that's out there I mean
people argue about Market profile tells
you a lot yeah it does it does and it
doesn't um and trust me i' I've spent a
lot of time trading with Market profile
and I find the order flow volume
footprint
chart much more
effective intraday um for intraday
trading you know I think market profiles
are are great for swing Traders but you
know if you're an intraday Trader
orderflow volume footprint chart is you
know is you know like uh high octane
fuel for your car so again you'll keep
your charts clean as much as possible
you know trade Traders think hey the
more indicators I have on a chart the
more chances I'll have of finding trades
and it's actually the opposite um you
know the more things you have on your
chart sometimes the more confused you
get you know the more squiggly lines you
have drawn on your chart the more
confusing it becomes it's information
overload and you know what do I mean is
you know a chart like this right you
start with your
normal Candlestick
chart then you start adding Binger bands
you know adx Mac
RSI um you know vwap is is the new
current thing and you know next thing
you know you got C their
channels you know this this is a chart I
put together sort of as a joke but you
know to sort of make my point but you
know what I I belong to a bunch of
groups on
Facebook where people post charts and I
see a chart like this I just shake my
head I scratch my
head you know it's you know they got
like RSI down here I don't know what
these bands are up in here um you know
then they got the lines drawn up in here
and you know it's I don't know I just
find it very confusing it's like what
okay well every time the bars come down
here you're supposed to buy it well okay
say oh yeah see it touched this bar down
here well actually touched it up here
and then it started moving down then you
say oh you see it got up here hit this
upper band you should sell it well what
about the time it hit this upper band
here it sold off then it came back up
sold off came back up um you know it
gets more confusing you know I mean
charts like this levels to watch for
fomc no offense to the guy you know if
you know if this is your chart I'm sorry
but uh if it works for you fantastic
okay I don't want to say don't have a
messy chart I mean if if if this is what
your chart looks like but you're making
money great don't stop it I mean don't
get me wrong don't stop it just because
I say you have to have a clean chart you
know I I have a friend likes to bet on
horses and I look at his his racing form
and he's got all sorts of arrows
squiggly lines triangles squares circles
next to the names next to the lines it's
like it's it's okay I said how do you
make Ser go I you know at the end of the
day I don't know sometimes it's the it's
the horse with the most marks on it um
and it's it's just like this okay what
levels to watch well you got every
single level on there it's almost like
you just you can draw a random line
actually I I did it as a joke one time I
just drew random lines on a chart and I
put it up I said people okay here's my
levels um this is what I was at at the
bank it's just a joke and you sure is
enough you know a couple of those levels
held you know people like hey yeah there
pretty good level and I'm like no you
know what I did it as a joke you say I
just drew random lines like what but it
you can almost do that sometimes
um you'll open yourself up to a you know
defends if it's it's one of these closet
technicians they'll you'll open yourself
up to a big discussion on random walk
Theory but you know yeah there's there's
lines know markets don't necessarily
move because of it cross the moving
average it doesn't cross be markets
don't move because oh RSI is at 60 you
know markets they don't care the RSI is
at 60 um you know markets move because
of people buying and selling and what
better information can you have than the
actual quantities that are trading at a
certain price and you know it's
funny there's this movie that came out
in the'80s called under the
rainbow and it's ridiculous movie it's
with Chevy Chase and Carrie Fisher rest
in
peace and it sort of you know when I saw
it I remember thinking you know when you
see a I mean no offense nothing
again you know I don't know what's
politically correct nowadays if you
could say or you say short people
but you know this is back in the 80s and
there wasn't as much political
correctness out there but
you watch a movie right like Austin
Powers there's a mini me right and you
think oh that's funny hey that's funny
well what can be more funny than if you
got one mini me in a movie then let's
get 150 mini Mes in the movie and the
movie will be 150 times funnier no it's
not sometimes yeah it's it becomes
ridiculous right and it's just like
having that with um you with with too
many lines and indicators on a chart um
you know it's like you even even the
headline in this movie you know uh you
know a giant comedy don't sell it short
but it's you know somewhere under the
rainbow way down low Chevy Chase car
Fisher and 150 midgets are fighting
valiantly to save the world against all
Oz you know it's just like one of those
things like hey if if you got one monkey
in a movie then and it's funny well if
we get a bunch of monkeys in a
movie then the movie will be you know
much more funnier right you know whether
it's you know you can say well I got one
talking fish in a movie let's get 100
talking fish and it'll be you know 100
times funnier no it doesn't work that
way and and having um you know as many
lines on a chart it just gets confusing
right and you don't know you can't you
get confused you what do I look at you
do I look at this do I look at this I
mean you know at the end of the day you
get a headache you know and you need to
start popping some Advils so
let me ask you a question are you
enjoying this webinar so far I hope so
you know I'm actually getting into it
and you know I like teaching this stuff
you know even though I don't have a
great teaching voice you know I do like
to spend time with with people and and
it's nice to get you know feedback from
from people and saying hey you know what
that was a great webinar i' I've learned
something you know order flows orderflow
makes more sense to me now so you know
what we've covered so far is you know
number one orderflow allows you to see
into the price bar and see the volume
traded to know what is really occurring
in the market number two how using
arbitrary levels for stops based on
dollar amounts is not very scientific or
prudent and you know I showed you how to
play stops at levels where the reason
for being in a trade is no longer there
and number three you know the more lines
you have drawn on your chart the more
confusing it becomes you know it's
information
overload okay so who wants to take their
trading to the next level if you do
put in the Box you know I'm ready the
chat box I'm ready then you know I I'll
know you know I like to have people
interested in in what I'm talking about
right so okay
okay so what I'm going to introduce to
you is the complete orderflow trading
package and what includes is the
orderflow volume footprint chart which
is the charts you saw generated that I
use in this
presentation um also includes a complete
home study course on trading with the
order flow it's 15 hours I I creaded it
myself and I I honestly I didn't want it
to be 15 hours but there's just so much
information that you originally I
thought 8 hours you I thought that' be
perfect you could do it on a Saturday
instead you could do it on Saturday and
Sunday you know I I really didn't want
to leave too much out so I I really went
uh went you know full blast on it to get
as much information in that trading
course as possible and you also get
access access to the orderflow trading
room you know it's a room that I run
from 8:00 a.m. to 10:00 a.m. Chicago
time where you know it's live
trading in the e- minis in the bonds the
five years and you know Dow mini Dow
Euro currency sometimes it really
depends and you know I discuss what I'm
seeing in the order flow right um you
know you get to see it in real time and
you I talk about what I'm thinking you
know what I anticipating based on the
order flow and it's it's a great
educational tool for people now I know
that you know not everybody can be in
there so I I try to record it you know
sometimes I I forget to hit record but
you know I've got archives going back a
year so there's a lot of information
there for you and you know the complete
orderflow trading package is all about
helping you become a better Trader right
to give you the confidence to trade
successfully fast right by teaching
you to understand what's really going on
in the price action and in 30 days or
less you know I I don't
think you know you should really take a
lot of time trying to learn it you know
that's why I created the course I have
the the trading room for you and you
know obviously the the trading guides
that I include with it um you know I I
think you know if you're
serious literally really in a week or
two I think you can get the hang of it
but you know I say 30 days because you
know I know people have jobs people have
families and they could only commit you
know maybe one or two hours a day to
trying to learn it but you know that's
fine you'll go at your own pace you
don't want to overwhelm
anybody and you know what you're going
to get is you're going to get the
orderflow trading software right again
that's the software that I use to
generate the charts that you saw in this
presentation now you know there's a lot
of orderflow trading software out there
some of which costs thousands and
thousands of dollars um you know without
naming names you know there there's a
few that's literally $5,000
is that there's at least two that cost
5,000 you know granted there are some
that are cheaper that are you know 200
bucks 100 bucks so there's one I think
you get for free um then I don't know if
they still offer it for free but you
know what good is it if if you don't
know how to use it right if you don't
know what you're looking at in the
market and honestly you know the the the
free versions I've messed around with
those a couple years ago and yeah
honestly I'm I'm not you know I know a
lot about computers but I'm no
programmer not by any stretch of the
means
of the imagination and it's just like
okay here here you can download it here
and then they have all these builds this
build this build this I don't even know
which one's the most recent and you you
try to put it on and it's just a
headache and honestly you know I don't
have the the time or the patience to try
and mess around with that you know so I
went to a programmer who actually
already has a software out there and I
actually gave them additional
requirements that I want to see in the
software based on how I trade order flow
so there's actually like
four um you know extra indicators
actually currently already programmed in
the software um you know that just not
available elsewhere actually a few
people have gone out and copied some of
these indicators and put it in theirs
but you know whatever
um you know they're not The Originators
and they don't really understand what to
look at you know I mean if you're making
a copy of
something you know people you know
sometimes they want to buy the uh you
know the the imitation iPhone or
something well it doesn't it's not as
good as the
original and you know I'm including my
guide to orderflow trading that's the
150 page book you know people do ask me
you know because they want to learn
orderflow if I sell it by itself and I
don't actually offer it out there for
free um it's it's more for people that
use my software and want to learn
trading with orderflow and you I got to
put a price on it it's $197 if if you
just want the book by itself I mean you
know legitimate good trading books are
not are not
cheap and I include done for you chart
templates so your charts just look like
the ones that I have in my trading room
you know so you add all that up it's
it's already over $1,000 you know what
can you spend $1,000 on right well you
can go out and you can buy the new
iPhone 7 um you know that's that's
$1,000 you know yeah iPhone 7 is great
do you need it no if you already have an
iPhone or you already have another phone
then then you don't need it I mean but
think about this right all of us have
disposable
income most of you guys you get your
paycheck each month and a percentage of
that goes towards movies candies
Starbucks you know going out to dinner
and things like that and I'm not asking
you to go into debt for this at all okay
I don't want you to go into debt to
learn how to trade what I'm asking is
you take some of that disposable income
that you're going to spend on movies and
going out to dinner and that kind of
stuff and instead of blowing it on
something
temporary and you're going to lose it
you know I'm ask you to make an
investment in yourself cu the money that
you put into this is ultimately going to
turn into more money for you right
you're investing in yourself I don't if
you people you guys are familiar with
this book um what's it called Rich Dad
Poor Dad right right Richard Robert
kosaki and you know in the book Rich Dad
Poor Dad he talks about the difference
between assets and
liabilities you know poor people buy
liabilities you know they buy cars they
buy TVs they buy boats well I say boats
but you know they buy the things they
put money in and the money disappears
you know what the rich people do is they
put the money into investment that
actually turns into more money for them
now you know that could be education
right to to better themselves right it's
it's it's you know I don't know where
where everybody works but you know
that's why companies pay people to go
back to school and get more education so
they can provide more value to the
company right they're they're not
becoming necessar
a liability to the company CU they're
adding value to the company right that's
why you you the companies pay for
people's educations continuing education
and all I'm asking right all I'm asking
you to do here is just divert some of
your disposable income into an
investment in yourself you know the
complete door flows trading package as
opposed to something that's going to
take money away from you you know you
want to buy Starbucks you know Starbucks
is not cheap six bucks
a six bucks a six bucks a drink now or
something like that something crazy
how much Starbucks do you buy you know
in a day and I know people that buy two
or three you buy one a day that's you
know at the end of the month that's you
know 100 bucks right imagine you just
cut out your
Starbucks you know then you then you
know you got that extra money you know
but people sometimes you like to piss
away their money I no offense if you do
that but you know I like my Starbucks
but you know what I also buy ground
coffee and make my own you know then
that that's me um you know i' I've
worked hard for for my money and
sometimes I I don't necessarily like to
you know sometimes I do Splurge but you
know sometimes if I can invest it in
myself then that's great you know like
you know I'm a parent right I got three
kids you know and if you have kids you
know I'm sure you realize right that you
want to give them the best education
that they have you want to invest in
them right that's why you want to send
them to good schools or um spend the
time you know going over their homework
with them because you know you want them
to have a good life and so you're
willing to invest in their future that
way and you
know investing your disposable income in
in education for yourself is is also
going to pay um pay dividends in the
future so you know if you only got that
right if you only got just you know the
15-hour trading course you know that
know those sorry that was bonus number
one I skipped over it it's bonus number
one right is the 15-hour orderflow
trading course right normally I sell
this every day
$297 and like I said you know this is
really a beginning to not end but um you
know if it was a college course it'd be
somewhere between you know freshman and
sophomore
year and you know with Advanced courses
you know in the future but take this
course you at the very least you'll come
out of it with with a much better
understanding of the market like I said
you know I've been involved in the
markets all my life and not just
as a you know I'll say a Trader
but you know people that trade in Prop
Shops that's that's all they know is
trading props you know I've been you
Lally on all sides you know I've traded
you know speculation I've traded for
hedging I've traded um you know on the
commercial side I I've seen the whole
supply chain you know I understand you
know how to think ahead not just the
next tick and you know so there there's
a lot
that uh how to say it there's there's
more to trading than just you know
trading the next tick you know sometimes
you have to have a bigger picture and
you know I so I try to put whatever I
know about orderflow into this course
right now granted you know it's 15 hours
and I do understand that 15 hours is is
a bit long for some people but again you
know it's it's there you don't have to
do it all in once you know you could
spend you know it's each course on each
lesson actually is probably between 20
to 40 minutes
long and there's one course at the end
it's like two hours two and a half hours
just because it's it's a review you know
and what it is it's it's several days
it's like a week of several different
markets and I just take you through
literally almost like seems like bar to
bar
over a week in in a few markets so if
you take that out you know each course
is only about 20 to to 45 minutes
length so again you know if you only got
that then you know that
alone with the
software with um you know with with the
software and and the course and the book
you know that would be worth the entire
investment that would help you you know
with your trading not just orderful
training but trading in general and you
know that would be worth the entire
investment if that's all I gave you it
would still be worth it but you know
you're getting more right on top of that
I'm also going to give
you going to give you the access to my
trading room it's it's free access and I
used to charge
$299 a month for it actually
and I've stopped that and the reason
I've stopped it is it's always been free
for users of the software it was people
that didn't use the software that I was
charging $299 a
month but I really want to concentrate
on people using the software because you
know you're using my software you're
going to be looking at the same things
I'm looking at and really if I'm going
to be teaching you it's best that you
have the same thing that I'm looking at
honestly and again it's two I used to
charge $2.99 a month for it and actually
when I say free access all right what I
mean is it's free for life you know I've
had people in that room for over a year
so imagine you know charging paying $300
a month for a trading
room each month for a year that's 3,000
you know three and a half thousand bucks
and you get access to it you know
granted it's not every day I because I
do need uh you know days off and
sometimes I do take you know around
certain holidays I do take off but you
know it's it's there it's it's a
resource for you and as you know as long
as you have the software it's it's free
for you you can come in you you can
watch the replay you can ask your
questions you know I'm I'm there for
you and you know the saying right money
replenishes right
so look right every month right or every
two weeks I don't know how you guys are
you get a paycheck right and the cool
thing is you get that paycheck you go
out pay your bills buy your groceries
you have disposable income you spend
that money and it disappears right then
what happens two weeks later you get
paid again right the money
replenishes and the cool thing is right
the
money about money is you know keeps
replenishing you know as long as you got
a job you know every two weeks it comes
back again keeps coming back over and
over again right
so let me ask you right if how do you
want to spend your time okay do you want
to spend your time you in your office or
you want to spend your time with your
children you know I'm I'm very fortunate
I could spend time with my children but
you know unlike money right time doesn't
come back okay you know once time is
gone you don't get that time back right
money your money will replenish every
two weeks because you'll keep getting
you know your paycheck but if you miss
your kid soccer game because you're at
the office you can't go back and get
that time that you spent in the
office you know to watch kid soccer game
again you can't it's just gone and it's
like that with trading and training
right
if if you you could have a way to get
from point A to point B in trading
quickly do you want to take it or do you
want to spend the next six months or a
year trying to figure everything out you
know would you just rather take a few
weeks to learn the important things of
trading that you can take and start
applying rather than trying to figure it
all out in the dark
um and you know basically waste all your
time right um you know honestly I think
you know it's much better to speed up
the process I mean you know I'm not
going to say you know throw money at the
problem you know I know guys that
uh you know if their toilet is is broke
they no I'll fix it you know they'll
spend trips going to Menards buying
stuff go I don't have this tool go about
oh wait I don't know how to do this go
look it up on YouTube figure it out you
know and meanwhile you know I'm just the
type of person hey call the plumber then
two hours later it's fixed I could I
could go use a toilet whereas you know
other people you know they just want to
try and do it themselves and in the end
cost more time more money than taking
the quick
route so you know break your old habits
right I want to ask you um you know I'm
sure everyone's been on these kinds of
webinars before and you get excited you
get fired up and then what happens you
do nothing nothing you know most people
do nothing they'll click off of this um
presentation and you know maybe some
will have made notes and will'll look
for it
in you know apply it to their trading
and you know honestly I think it's sad
that people don't do anything CU you
know I just showed you you know ways
that many Traders are using right now
using orderflow to you know improve
their trading and you know have the
confidence to trade successfully right
so what are you going to do you're going
to go back uh tomorrow whenever the
Market opens up again and do nothing you
know then use the same ways that you've
been trading the same ways that you've
been losing money you know the same ways
that everybody else is trading losing
money um you know I understand you know
old habits are hard to break you know
and that's why I like this picture you
know it's like the girl is telling the
guy you know hey it's time to move on
and you know some people they they don't
want to give up you know and you know
that that's the problem that lot of
people face is they don't want to let go
of their old habits know their old ways
and if you're going to be
successful right you have to figure out
how to break those habits that are
costing you time more importantly
costing you money and you know that's
why I think you know this the orderflow
trader the volume footprint chart the
home study course the access to the
trading room is going to help you break
those habits those bad habits that you
have in your trading now I can come here
and you know again I could help you I
could show you all these different
tools and you know give you access to
all this education and the trading room
but you know if you're not going to do
it right if you're not going to want to
do it then you're just going to fall
back into your exact old habits you're
just going to keep doing what doesn't
work and you know the the definition is
insanity is is doing the same thing over
and over expecting a different result
and
you know honestly if everything I just
talked about you know over the last hour
you know if you're not willing to apply
it then is just going to be completely
useful because you just go back to your
old habits so really the only way to
break your old habits is to investing
yourself right now you know you have the
tools I'm giving you the tools to break
the habits and you know take your
trading to the next
level so you know again just to recap
you know you what you get is the
orderflow trader software the 15 page
guide to trading orderflow my chart
templates you know access to the 15-hour
orderflow trading course again you know
it's it's it's on I say on demand but
you know you can go in and you could
watch it you know however long you need
to take it's it's there for you whether
you know you want to watch it as soon as
you get access to it or you want to
watch it a month from now that's fine
you know it's up to you and you know you
also get access to the trading room
again you know if I know a lot of people
work you know I know a lot of people are
overseas can't attend the training room
you can go in and watch the archives for
that day if you want um you know
honestly there's sometimes there's just
nothing going on and there's not a lot
to talk about but usually there's one or
two things that um really is interesting
in the in one market at least so there
is there is some nuggets to be had in
there and you know I'm also going to
give
you my top three orderflow trade up so
at least you know you have a you have a
um you know some things to look for in
the market with
orderflow now remember you know
orderflow information you know
information alone is not going to save
you you know for the
last I don't know how long I've been
talking for about over an hour already
I've shared a ton of information with
you but as you know information alone is
not going to save you right you need the
orderflow trader volume footprint chart
the home study course
you need access to the trading room you
know because that's what's going to help
you get to the next level right um and
and that's what you want you want to get
to the next
level so you know again you know sort of
recap I don't know how that jumped up
price so this
is uh you get all that information right
I mean what's your
excuse you know people in life they can
have two things they have money they
could have excuses right it's okay you
have two options right you can sign up
now you can make money
trading have the confidence to trade
successfully or you come up with some
excuse why you couldn't afford it you
know why you couldn't do it this time
you don't have enough time whatever
that's fine you know but the reality is
you can't have both okay you can have
money you can have excuses you got to
decide which one you
want you know I don't know about you but
I'd rather have money and you know and
that's why I think that you know if you
want money again I'm not trying to say
you know be greedy and think of money
here no not not at all um you know does
does money solve all the world's
problems no but it makes you know life
more comfortable um so again you know
there's two types of
people two types of Traders actually I
say two types of people there two types
of Traders you know there's the guy on
the
left that you know maybe he's tried and
failed and he likes to blame
others for his failure you doesn't like
to spend the time and the energy to
practice and learn they just and ultim
what it comes down to is they don't take
action they don't take decisive action
in wanting to
learn
and I don't know about you but you know
honestly I don't like working with
people like that those people are are
generally never successful either in in
Life or you know not even in trading but
you know even in life they they tend to
sort of go through life um you know
blaming other people you know my sister
has a boyfriend and yeah he's kind of
kind of a loser I mean I hate to say it
but you know it's my sister's boyfriend
and you know but he blames everybody
else for his his problems in his life
you know it's like man you know take
some action you know do something you
know shave get a haircut get a job you
know there there's you can do whatever
you want with your life you know that's
the great thing about
um in the United States at least I mean
you you could go out you know and do
things with your life and you know if
but it all comes down to taking action
right um you know the soccer player here
you know it's he's you know he's one of
the top soccer players in the world but
he works hard at his game you know even
though he's very good skills he still
goes out and he practices he works at
improving his game and you know in
trading you should be looking striving
to do the same thing and you know the
people that I like to work with you know
are people like you you know you stayed
on this webinar so long myself and you
know people that when they watch this
webinar they hear it they understand it
and more importantly they step up and
they want to produce and boom you know
they they want to come out here and get
results and make things happen you know
they want to put the ball in the back of
the net so to speak so again you know
you can do this too I mean look guys you
know this is the deal
right you've been trying to make more
money trading right and and have
confidence to trade successfully you
know again you know confidence is a big
thing in trading and Order flow trading
with order flow is going to help you
take better trades and you know what I
want to say right now is is
say how to say it you know goodbye um
you know say goodbye to losing trades
say goodbye to not understanding the
markets you know because you know once
you understand
orderflow you know these bad habits you
know bad way of trading in the past you
know is is going to be gone and you know
you're not going to be taking these same
losing trades that you know you took in
the past right I mean you could do it
too I mean this is me and Singapore at
the F1 and you know I mean you know this
is you know some of the perks of of
trading you know they they give you you
know the lifestyle that you want right
and the truth is you know I'm just a
normal person you know I'm nothing
special I'm a normal guy just like you
if I could do it again you know I came
from a background I had no experience
you I didn't know anybody in the markets
when I first started well I say don't
get me wrong I I knew somebody that's
how I got my job but beyond that I I
didn't know anybody on the floor and I I
worked my way up and I learned as much
as I
can and you know I promise you can do it
with you know this orderflow Trader
package I've put together for you and
you know that's what's going to make
being successful a reality for you and
you know again you know what you're
going to get is you going to get the
orderflow trader software package the
guide to orderflow trading you know my
templates access to the 15-hour trading
course access to the trading room the
top three trade setups and you know
total value of that is is almost $2,000
you know it's not cheap right but but
I've got a special offer for you um I'll
give you all that for just
$999 right if that's you know that's
quite a lot of information you're going
to get on you know just even if you
don't have the the software say you got
your own software um you know to get
access to the trading room and and the
course by itself I said you know this
access is $299 a month normally but you
can get it forever you get it for a year
you could go in a year from now still
log in you know and use it so even if
you go you know four times it already
pays for itself right there I mean four
months I say four times but you know you
can just you could keep going and
accessing it for as as long as you want
I mean that's what it's there for it's a
resource for people that um you know
that really are serious about learning
with uh with order
flow so again you got two choices right
um you know I had two choices when I was
putting this package together first
choice I can make it really cheap charge
like I don't know 100 bucks well I say
100 bucks I can just charge for the the
software and sell tons of people
everyone have access to it and you know
that was one option okay but you know
the problem with that is I just can't
put all the time and effort resources to
really serve you so you know instead of
selling you know 10,000
copies know 10,000 people at at 90 bucks
bucks what I want to do you know I I
because I really want to help you is I
want to give you more attention right so
I I have to charge more um you know
there's time you know again you know I'm
spending two hours of my trading
day that you know I'm committed to
answering your questions you know during
the trading day you know I could be
trading that time and sometimes I do
take trades in the room sometimes not
because I'm busy really it's more about
education than than my own trading at
that time and that's Prime Time trading
honestly um 10 8:00 a.m. to 10: a.m. but
you know what that's fine I'm willing to
make that sacrifice because I want
people to learn you know do you want to
be the sheep and just follow the crowd
or do you want to be you know the girls
roping the cattle you know um you do you
want to be in control or do you just
want to follow um you know everybody
else so that's why you got two choices
now one you can go and invest in
yourself get
started and you know I say you know
within the next 30 days you can have
entire system up and running and you
know trading a method that makes sense
you know that that makes sense with you
most importantly and it's not a method
where oh you have this line you know it
got up to overbought so you got to sell
or you know we crossed the zero line so
you got to buy no that's not trading you
know you're not making decisions you're
just basically following squiggly lines
on a chart and you know choice number
two is you can end this webinar right
now you know go to sleep tonight
tomorrow you wake up and do
nothing same thing you've been doing all
this time and then you're going to
complain why you're not making money in
the markets you know why are you still
losing every trades why you blowing up
accounts you know honestly
the you know people you know they see
the price
right they see the price of the software
they say w $999 that's that's very
expensive well what's more expensive you
know a one-time payment of
$999 or continue what you're doing and
blowing up account after account you
know I mean know maybe every two or
three months you keep putting money into
your account because you're losing money
well you know that that that's the the
part you know the education money you
the money you spend on education is
there with you and once you learn
something it's there you know whether
you access that information you know in
your brain tomorrow or 5 years from now
it's it's in your brain right but you
know money when it's lost in the market
it's gone you know trying to get it back
is sometimes the the hardest thing in
the world you know you just can't get it
back you got to make more back to get it
back and you know so you got to decide
right you have to decide what you want
in life you know you want to go back to
doing what everybody else is doing what
you've been doing you know losing money
being a sheep in the
market U I'm guessing not right
otherwise honestly I don't think it
would have lasted this long in the
webinar you know if you really want to
learn trading you know I don't want to
say make money it's more of you know
learning how to trade you know really
it's just it's it's a life skill right
once you know how to trade you know it's
going to really help you out in in
negotiation you know go buy a car you
you can tell you know you can you can
it's going to help you out in in
everyday life and you know you showed up
today because you think you need help
right
so again you got two choices get the
help you need to fix the problem or just
keep back keep going back to doing what
you're already doing you know and and
the problem's still going to still going
to persist and again you're not going to
you're not going to solve anything
and you're just going to you know then 6
months from now you're still going to be
losing money or thinking I need to learn
how to trade and you know why wait that
6 months why waste more time waste more
money you know get the package now it's
only 999 so again you know now or later
what do you want to do um you know
honestly sometimes you I know I've been
in I'll say I've been in this position
but you
know um contemplating life you know and
when you're not doing well trading you
know um I was very fortunate I've only I
think ever lost my I say lost my job
ever almost lost my job on a bad trade
but um there was there was a trade that
I did in I I traded NASDAQ mini NASDAQ
instead of e Minis
and I missed the
move and in the snps the move you know
was worth about 130,000 this was a long
time ago go back in the what was this uh
19 late like 1998 or something like that
no it was 2000 actually I remember
because it was the election of bush and
Gore and S&P in NASDAQ shot up and I
accidentally traded mini NASDAQ for some
reason I just clicked on the wrong line
on the screen and and I thought you know
the group that I was trading for you
know we we we thought we booked like
$150,000 on a 10 lot in The e- Minis and
we didn't
um we only booked uh it was 23,000 on
the ten lot of the NASDAQ that I bought
and oh boy I I thought that was it I I
was now I'm going to lose my job
over this fortunately I didn't but you
know the feeling you know sometimes when
you know you have a a losing trade or
you do something wrong is is not a good
feeling right and so I I I know what
it's like to be in this position where
you know do you want to continue trading
or do you not not you know I I did think
about my life choices after that I I say
I I I didn't want to think of kilman
myself but thinking do do I still you
know if I'm going to lose my job do I
still want to be in this market or not
uh trading the markets
so you know the point is um you know do
you want to be successful and you have
to keep on going on but you don't don't
keep on going on doing the wrong thing
you know learn a way to trade learn a
method of trading that's going to help
you and put you ahead in
life and again you know you can get
started the fastest way is you know get
started with the orderflows trading
package and you know people think or act
like money is evil that they look at it
as a bad thing money is not bad I don't
want to go in no no no Gordon gecko
speech you know greed is good or
anything you know again money is a tool
right and you spend money right now to
get something bigger in return it's a
tool for exchange that's what money is
you know when people trade they're
exchanging money for commodity and you
know in you go to a grocery store you
give them money to give you food right
you're exchanging it for stuff that's
all it is you're exchanging money with
me for knowledge and a method of trading
that you know will put you head and
shoulders above everybody else so you
know wow it's not yet 90 minutes but you
know if you're still stuck
around congratulations um you can
download my ebook hidden trade
opportunities by going to this um link
here www. orderflows dcom webinar and
you'll scroll down to this button here
it says download hidden trade locations
and you should be able to download it
it's a it's a instant PDF form so you'll
have to you just download it save it to
your hard drive and you can open it so
again thanks everybody for taking the
time out of your day to watch this I
mean I know that we're all busy this
went on I think this is one of the
longest webinars I've ever done um so I
hope you got something out of it and I
hope that you know what I said resonates
with you um makes sense with you and you
can see how orderflow can and will
transform your trading you know um there
there's I just scratch the surface
actually in this presentation there's so
much more that you'll you'll learn on um
you know once you get access to the
trading room once you start watching
some of the videos in the trading course
your eyes will really be opened and you
know it just be like a whole new world
that you know it' be like the way I
would I would uh liken it is you know if
you've ever had the surgery for your
eyes right so you don't have to wear
glasses can't think of what it's called
right now off top of my head but you
know one of my friends had it and
described it to me as like waking up the
day after opening up your eyes without
need eating your glasses it's like
everything's in focus and you know
that's what it's like with orderflow you
know once you understand orderflow and
what you're looking at in the market
when you look at the market on your
chart it all you know it makes a lot
more sense than if you just looking at
bars you know simple plain bars on a
chart so again thanks for watching this
go to this link here
www.com
webinar.
HTML uh You Know download the the hidden
trade locations guide and you know I
hope to see you on the inside honestly I
do you know I mean I like working with
uh with with new Traders and you know I
like you know even even if you're
existing Trader um you know I'm always
interested in hearing people's stories
you know knowing what works for them and
you know going from there you know it's
I mean that that's what I don't claim to
know everything there is to know about
the markets and you know once in a while
people call up to me and say hey you
know what I got this um you know this is
how I look at the market and you know
every once in a while I I do come across
some really gems in trading and you know
it helps me just as it's just as I'm
trying to help you so again thanks for
watching this and I hope to see you on
the inside bye everyone